my first recipe is so quick and easy but
seriously impressive
and deceptively cheap homemade gnocchi
making your enoki is so simple to do yet
the results are absolutely stunning and
it's a great way
of using up leftover baked potatoes
you can make nokia just with flour and
eggs however the potato gives it a nice
light sort of creamy fluffy texture cut
them in half
take your spoon and scoop the inside
of those potatoes i'm using leftover
baked potatoes
but this really works as well with
leftover ball potatoes
two choices you can get a fork and sort
of mash the potato and get it nice and
light and fluffy
or this little gadget it's called a
ricer
i suppose it's a posh word for a potato
masher
just squeeze gently you can see how nice
and light it is almost like fluffy
little strands of potato you can do this
when the potatoes are hot
it'll go through the rice so much
quicker
just slice that off there
now a nice spoon of okata
a little touch of salt and pepper it's
really important to season
the mixture as we go along otherwise the
nokia becomes really bland
flour over the ricotta sieved so there's
no lumps
one delicious egg give that a little
whisk
now make a little well in the center
you want a nice soft pliable ball of
dough
give that a really good mix get some
time flowers in there
and this time is light fragrant and it's
just a really nice herb
and with the ricotta it tastes brilliant
just pick the little tips
the time flowers next
flour your hands generously and knead
the mixture into a dough
fold in and push and basically what it's
doing is get it nice and smooth
as it starts to get a little bit wet and
just add
a little touch of flour we want
something really nice and soft
now don't overwork it it stops the nokia
from
expanding when it hits the pan that's
exactly what i want
a nice sort of soft fragrant ball
cut the ball in half lightly flour
the hands and just roll it gently just
think of a
a big long cigar the mixture will start
getting a little bit sort of wetter but
do not add lots of flour
now lightly flour the knife so when you
slice the gnocchi
it doesn't stick cut the dough into
bite-sized pieces
just take your finger dip it in the
flour and push down
why i want my knocking to look like a
pillow and for me the most important
part there is that
not one of them are identically the same
shape water on
bring up to the boil little touch of
olive oil in there lightly flour your
hand
lift up the gnocchi in to the rolling
boiling water
turn that pan to stop them from sticking
at the bottom
and let them simmer and they start to
sort of tell you
they're cooked when they start floating
get a pan on
get that nice and hot now they're just
starting to come up to the top
and you can continue cooking them like
that i like blanching them in the water
taking them out
and then frying them to study the
gnocchi heat olive oil in a frying pan
gently lift up and look they've doubled
in size
drain it get rid of the excess water and
straight in
to the hot pan
[Music]
this is where they start to take on a
completely different texture nice crisp
sauteed texture on the outside nokia
loves
fresh pepper so
pepper in
you can see as i start turning them
you've got this really nice little sort
of
brown color
and they're almost popping up now like
little parcels
so i want them nice and sauteed both
sides but light
and creamy in the center
fresh garden peas in
and the butter gives it a really nice
sort of bernoulli flavor on the end
beautiful a little bit of fresh thyme
over the peas and then finally i want to
lift it up
fresh lemon zest the lemon over
[Music]
smells incredible
and then finally seal the deal with a
touch of grated parmesan cheese
give your veg some attitude and you'll
get amazingly elegant dishes on a budget
that are always guaranteed to impress
what more do you want from great cooking
cheap to make easy to cook and
absolutely stunning
i absolutely love bacon bread there's
something
really satisfying about doing it and
this focaccia recipe is
very hands-on but the end result is
something
really really tasty
first off start with the dough tip 500
grams of strong bread flour
into a mixing bowl and add 20 grams of
semolina
that gives the focaccia its sort of
rustic charm
now there's one thing for catching needs
it's really good seasoning
you can't season bread after it's baked
so it's got to go in right the very
beginning
sprinkling 15 grams of dried yeast take
some warm water
and then 50 mils of olive oil top of
that water
that gives it this really nice silky
rich texture
make a little well mix up that yeast
water
and oil in start off with your fingers
keep your fingers nice and open it's
like a little sort of whisk
going in there i'm looking for a really
nice sort of relaxed
dough
now let's just start to come together
touch more water
with oil in there give it a little swirl
and then again the secret is to sort of
knead it gently don't overwork it
it's a sort of easy bread to make a nice
one to start off with when you're making
bread for the first time
basically kneading means just knit it
together just hanging
lightly flour your board and let's just
knead that focaccia
into a nice smooth dough make sure you
don't over add
too much flour otherwise it sort of
dries out the dough
something quite magical about making
bread you can switch off
and lose yourself my first job for a
three mission star establishment
was a baker i was 22 years of age i used
to start at midnight
i was under such a tight schedule one
o'clock
white bread done two o'clock brown bread
three o'clock sourdough
four o'clock cheese bread five o'clock
prove bake
six o'clock crack them open and taste
it was amazing beautiful
yeah looks stunning it hasn't even risen
yet
leave your dough to rise in a warm place
until it's doubled in size
we call this proving
[Music]
look at that beautiful a lot of chefs
sort of
need it for the second time but i'm
looking for a really nice light
aerated for catcher take your tray
a touch of olive oil in there season it
at the bottom
really important that's the exciting
thing about focaccio you've got that
really nice sort of salty top
and salty bottom and just with a touch
of olive oil
on your hands gently push that in
almost massage it into the corners it's
possible to put
sort of olives and tomatoes and garlic
through the dough but
it never really allows the dough to sort
of aerate properly
when you put so much ingredients in i'm
gonna stick mine on top
use your finger and sort of just push
them in
salt on top some pepper on top as well
i want some nice fresh amazing rosemary
just hold the stalk
and just pull off and then just sprinkle
down
generous in the rosemary really
important to have that nice
fragrance on top of the fuckachu finish
it off before it goes in
with a little drizzle of olive oil so it
almost sinks in those little pockets of
flavor olive tomato rosemary and olive
oil
into the oven bake your focaccia
at 200 degrees for 30 to 35 minutes
smells delicious
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
you can hear how crispy that is you
can't beat
a nice warm fresh slice of home-cooked
focaccia
it's rustic charming and it's the
perfect way
to start baking making homemade for
catcher
is so addictive
[Music]
my next amazingly aromatic recipe is
roasted squash hummus
[Music]
start with my take on razal hanut a
classic moroccan spice blend
in a dry pan toast cinnamon cloves
coriander
fenugreek and fennel seeds
then add mustard seeds and cumin
when the seeds start to pop they're
ready
add paprika and grind into a fine powder
for the hummus peel and chop butternut
squash
put on a baking tray and add garlic
simply bashed and chopped ginger
with olive oil season and sprinkle over
the spice mix
then roast in a hot oven for half an
hour until soft
allow to cool and place in a blender
add tahini a nutty paste made from
sesame seeds
cooked chickpeas a dash of lemon juice
and a drizzle of olive oil
blitz until luxuriously creamy and
textured
spices toasted for maximum flavor
amazing roasted squash hummus
my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level
of flavour and excitement
soft fiery and irresistible spicy
pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination
when it comes to brunches you don't have
to stick to the old standbys
these delicious spicy pancakes are
really great alternative but more
importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up and then just slice
nice little thin slices in there
and then keep that bunched up shake the
chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now garlic
nice now add olive oil to your toasted
cumin seeds
and then with the garlic ginger and
chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but
the time i spent in india everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary
into your bowl and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and look at the color
an instant change leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes
across the pan all the potatoes stained
i want them sort of absorbing all that
really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes and it really helps to bring
out
the spice beautifully
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic
chili ginger and cumin seeds a touch
of salt and pepper nothing worse than
the bland
pancake
one whole egg milk hold the jug with one
hand
and whisk we have a secret to get that
really nice smooth paste
but whisk in that egg first and brings
it together
and then you're milking
then put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it
not going lumpy look at that
milk here
the secret for me is to have a nice thin
mix now
just a little teaspoon of oil
that helps to bring a nice crispy edge
to the mixture now just taste
that's the texture pan on the larger the
pan the better
it helps to create a nice thin even
surface i want that
mix going all the way around the pan
before you put the mixture
into the pan make sure you give your
pancake mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
around
so it's really nice and thin i want to
see the ginger the garlic
that's what i'm looking for in there now
back onto the heat it only starts to
remove
from the bottom of the pan and lifts
itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off
the pan a little shake that releases it
and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the
confidence tossing
then use a spatula and turn it over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge
around the side the color on the pancake
is so important
now roll it round and just let it slide
out
beautifully
now for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll that
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there
pull it back and roll
useful the delicious pancakes are ready
to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat just mix chopped
coriander with natural yogurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious
spicy pancakes amazing